yesterday December 7th 1941 a date which
will live in infamy the United States of
America was suddenly and deliberately
attacked I am Nick Gillespie with Reason
TV and today we're talking with Craig
Shirley author most recently of December
1941 31 days that changed America and
saved the world Craig thanks for talking
to us that Nick thank you it's at the
table for America before Pearl Harbor
we're at peace but it was an uneasy
peace
nobody wanted to get involved in the
European war Gallup had done polling
that something on the order of seventy
percent of the American people were
opposed to our entry in the European war
we weren't even thinking about this the
draft had already I mean there were one
vote in October 1941 the House of
Representative by one vote kept the
draft in place that's right and people
have been called up but nobody nobody
wanted to go to war no no the only way
you could go to war if you were an
American was to the the Chinese Air
Force was taking American fliers so you
had to resign your commission and then
reenlist in the Chinese Air Force to
fight the Empire of Japan did anybody do
that
no yeah there were a number of officers
who did that sure okay so then we have
the Pearl Harbor attack and everything
changes and a large part of your book is
about how America went from being non
interventionist or resolutely
isolationist even to something else talk
about the vote that was taken after
FDR's famous speech it goes very quickly
in the House and the Senate on December
8th it was unanimous in the Senate and
one vote in the house yes you're not
Rankin yeah talk about Jeannette Rankin
and she's a very interesting person she
was there on time yeah she was a very
interesting and and I think there was it
took a lot of courage for her she had
very principled reason she said I cannot
ask somebody to go fight in the war that
I can't find her myself
now she'd also been in Congress in 1917
and it voted then against entry into the
European war but she was joined by about
50
there's a Congress then so she wasn't
alone but this time she was all alone
she after the vote in 1917 she was
driven out and essentially driven out of
Congress and been out in the political
wilderness for 20 years and then came
back and was elected again in Montana in
1940 and then of course after 42
shouldn't even bothered to seek
reelection because she knew she would
win how much was the anti-war sentiment
in America born out of the experience in
World War one but it was useless well
we're in Europe we had historical
admonitions George Washington advised
against entangling alliances in his
farewell address the Monroe Doctrine
essentially codified it and said to
Europe you know you stay out of our
affairs and will essentially stay out of
your affairs we were briefly
internationalist in the spanish-american
war but then we were trenched very
quickly we were briefly internationalist
in World War one but then we really
retreated very quickly the World War one
left a horrible taste in Americans
people's mouths there was a saying going
around America after World War one all
we got out of this was death and debt
and George M : and by 1940 FDR is
running for his third term and is
telling in an October of 1940 he's
telling American mothers I will not send
your sons to die in another European war
because he's feeling the political
pressure the America first movement is a
very respectable political movement in
America in in December on December 6
1941 it was not only led by Lindbergh
but also involved were EE Cummings Walt
Disney Lowell Thomas L Smith there were
a lot of respectable individuals on the
left and the right who are involved with
the America first movement they were so
strong they'd actually announced plans
to open up campaign offices in all the
congressional districts for the 42
elections to support the most
isolationist candidate whether it was
Republican or Democrat they were at one
issue okay so then you know December 7th
comes 2,400 Americans are killed at the
at Pearl Harbor that's gone how did
America react to to Pearl Harbor
instantly with anger with rage with a
sense of revenge obviously a sense of
loss morning now talk about
Pearl Harbor one of the things you
mentioned in the book is that some
people thought it was possible to go to
war against Japan but not Germany sure
that was yeah that was a non-starter we
were attacked on the Sabbath we declared
war on the eighth not until the 11th
dude Germany and Italy declare war on
the United States and it's interesting I
detected nothing in this country there's
no outcry between the 7th and the 11th
for America to go to war with with
Germany in Italy as we we definitely
definitely want to go to war with Japan
as a matter of fact in God we were going
through Henry Stimson's papers who was
of course the Secretary of War under
Roosevelt in his papers we found a
typewritten draft from the evening of
December 7th of a declaration of war
against Japan and Germany and Italy but
obviously it was junked and probably for
political considerations as much as
anything because there was a strong
German population in the United States
especially on the East Coast it was a
strong Italian population and and
support especially on the East Coast so
that was junked and we only declared war
on Japan so it's only after Germany and
Italy declare war on us that we respond
in kind how do you compare Pearl Harbor
to 9/11 the country stayed unified for
much longer after December 7th than it
did after September 11th there was also
had long stumbles into gross violations
of civil liberties in this country after
December 7th as there was after December
11th Japanese Americans German Americans
Italian Americans the the Roosevelt
government took all over all the
commercial radio stations in America and
dictated dictated programming
requirements there was a woman in Kansas
who was sentenced to two years in prison
because her son her two sons in public
school didn't recite the Pledge of
Allegiance in Chicago a man was fined
200 dollars at a movie theater because
when Roosevelt's image came up on the
screen he said something he yelled
something but it so anyway so there was
a lot of trampling of constitutional
rights and civil rights in the days
after December 7th as the
after September 11 you you talked about
in the book how December this month
December 1941 was the hinge point when
America went from being kind of an
isolationist or non interpret an
isolationist not just simply in foreign
policy but it emerged onto the world
stage you talk a little bit about that
well is mañana laughter World War one we
reject the League of Nations after World
War two we embrace the United Nations
and I'm not making a moral judgment
about it's just simply a historical fact
talk about your next project you've got
another book coming out in rapid
succession what is that about this is a
Titleist citizen note but working on it
for the last two years it's a political
biography of Newt Gingrich but it's
mostly on his early life it's from 1973
to 1994 and it culminates with the
Republican earlier hoping him take over
Congress in 1994 so I've been spending a
lot of hours with Gingrich interviewing
him and talking about that time but also
talking about the current state of
affairs and play and that'll be amazed
that'll be coming out from Thomas Nelson
in the spring yes yes yeah well I want
to thank you Craig Shirley I'm Nick
Gillespie for recent TV and today we've
been talking with Craig Shirley author
most recently of December 1941 31 days
that changed America and saved the world
Thank You Nick